si usted es hombre y tiene cáncer de
vejiga su médico puede recomendar la
cistectomía radical robótica para quitar
la glándula y la glándula de la próstata
su vejiga está ubicada en su pelvis
detrás del hueso púbico
sus riñones producen la orina que viaja
por la uretra hasta su vejiga donde se
almacena hasta que usted está listo para
orinar
su glándula de la próstata está ubicada
debajo de su vejiga pasando por la
próstata está la uretra el tubo por el
que sale la orina de su cuerpo
cada uno de sus conductos deferentes
combina con una vesícula seminal
para formar un conducto eyaculatorio que
se une a su glándula prostática
la capa más interna de su vejiga se
llama epitelio celular transicional o
urotelio
el carcinoma uroterial o la célula
transicional el tipo más común de cáncer
de vejiga comienza en esta capa cuando
una célula normal crece fuera de control
a medida que las células del cáncer se
multiplican se forma un tumor El tumor
puede formar un bulto dentro de su
vejiga o invadir de forma más profunda
en la pared de la vejiga antes del
procedimiento se le colocará una vía
intravenosa o ive
usted puede recibir antibióticos vía
intravenosa para disminuir la
posibilidad de infecciones
se le administrará anestesia general
se le insertará un tubo respiratorio por
la boca y en la tráquea para ayudarle a
respirar durante la operación
se le insertará un catéter de fowly en
la vejiga para drenar la orina
su cirujano realizará una pequeña
incisión cerca de su ombligo e insertará
un tubo plástico llamado puerto
se bombeará gas dióxido de carbono a su
abdomen a través de este puerto
el gas inflará su abdomen lo que le dará
al cirujano más espacio para ver y mover
las herramientas quirúrgicas
después de inflar su abdomen se
insertará una cámara de alta definición
en este puerto
su cirujano realizará incisiones
adicionales del puerto para instrumentos
robóticos así como para instrumentos
usados por los asistentes junto al
paciente
un asistente insertará todas las
herramientas robóticas por estos puertos
A diferencia de los instrumentos
laparoscópicos estándar estas
herramientas pueden rotar 360 grados y
tienen mayor flexibilidad que la muñeca
humana
Sentado en una consola especial tu
cirujano operará los brazos robóticos y
la cámara con controles tipo joystick Y
pedales a pie una computadora traducirá
los movimientos exactos de los dedos de
su cirujano en movimientos precisos de
las herramientas quirúrgicas
a la vez un sistema de visión de alta
definición ofrecerá una vista
estereoscópica aumentada en tres
dimensiones del área quirúrgica
con los brazos robóticos en posición su
cirujano cortará ambos uréteres cerca de
la conexión con su vejiga
luego se cortará cada conducto deferente
luego el cirujano cortará su uretra
justo debajo de la próstata
estos cortes liberan su vejiga y
próstata para que se puedan quitar
los nódulos linfáticos cercanos a su
vejiga y próstata serán quitados para
determinar si su cáncer se ha diseminado
debido a que se ha quitado su vejiga su
cirujano deberá reconstruir un nuevo
trayecto para pasar la orina desde su
cuerpo
su cirujano creará este nuevo trayecto
usando una sección de su intestino
delgado en uno de tres modos
si usted recibe un conducto ileal un
extremo de la sección intestinal se
unirá a la superficie de su abdomen
llamado estoma
su cirujano sellará el otro extremo y
unirá su uretra a este
su orina drenará a una bolsa unida al
estómago
si usted recibe un depósito de
continencia urinaria su cirujano
realizará una bolsa expandida de una
sección de su intestino
su orina drenará a través de un catéter
al estómago
Si recibe una Neo vejiga o un sustituto
de vejiga su cirujano realizará un
depósito de una sección de su intestino
y lo colocará donde solía estar su
vejiga
su cirujano conectará la parte superior
de esta vejiga a sus uréteres y la parte
inferior a su uretra
usted orinará contrayendo los músculos
abdominales lo cual creará presión en su
Neo vejiga para vaciarla
al final del procedimiento se cerrarán
las pequeñas incisiones con puntos de
sutura grapas pegamento quirúrgico o con
vendajes de cierre
después del procedimiento se le retirará
el tubo respiratorio y se lo trasladará
al área de recuperación para controlarlo
le darán medicamentos para el dolor si
fuese necesario usted puede continuar
recibiendo antibióticos por vía
intravenosa la mayoría de los pacientes
son dados de alta del hospital 7 o 10
días después del procedimiento si usted
recibió una Neo vejiga su catéter se
quitará 7 días después del procedimiento